[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una confesión de mayor
quiero ser como bruce dickinson el
cantante de iron maiden y de paso os voy
a dar un consejo si tenéis la
oportunidad de escuchar a la doncella en
directo no lo dejéis pasar porque
realmente merece la pena
aquí salimos mi hermana y yo en el año
2016 cuando yo todavía conservaba el
pelo pero volvamos al señor jus
dickinson no contento con ser el
cantante de heavy metal más emblemático
de todos los tiempos y el señor
dickinson es también locutor de radio
piloto de aviones y presidente de una de
las empresas más modernas de aviación y
os preguntaréis pero que tiene que ver
iron maiden con la política porque os
hablamos de bruce dickinson en visual
político pues la razón no es otra que
ésta
el cantante de iron maiden bruce
dickinson y su empresa cardiff aviation
firman un acuerdo para gestionar las
aerolíneas nacionales de yibutí cardiff
aviation es una empresa de mantenimiento
de aviones comerciales podríamos decir
que iron maiden ha aterrizado en yibutí
pero en este caso llegaron no para tocar
música sino para vender aviones entrenar
a los pilotos y diseñar todo el sistema
para que ahora las aerolíneas de este
país
erc iu wood y puedan funcionar por su
cuenta pero esperad un momento porque
aquí llega lo realmente importante
pensaréis que las líneas aéreas de un
país como yibutí no son gran cosa verdad
se trata de un país pobre situado en el
cuerno de áfrica y con una población que
ni siquiera llega al millón de
habitantes
[Música]
sin embargo y si os dijera que yibutí
tiene todas las posibilidades de
convertirse en el nuevo dubai y si bruce
dickinson fuera uno de los primeros
visionarios que decide invertir en este
país pensando bien y fijaos en el mapa
esto de aquí es yibutí esto de aquí es
el canal de suez y esto otro es el mar
rojo por ejemplo cualquier barco
petrolero que quiera salir de abu dhabi
con destino a europa tiene que pasar por
el mar rojo
esos teléfonos móviles chinos que
compramos en españa' también viajan por
el mar rojo en total uno de cada diez
barcos mercantes que viajan por el mundo
pasa por las costas de yibutí y no os
creáis que su mar tranquilo habéis oído
hablar de los piratas somalíes pues
somalia es esto de aquí
y esto otro es eritrea que tampoco es
precisamente un remanso de paz y
tranquilidad y esto de aquí es yemen que
está en guerra resulta que yibutí es el
único país pacífico que encontramos en
esta zona pero no sólo eso si seguís
visual politing desde hace tiempo ya
sabéis que llovía es uno de los países
que más rápido está creciendo en todo el
planeta se está consolidando como toda
una potencia en el sector textil y tiene
más de 90 millones de habitantes y
sabéis que etiopía no tiene salida al
mar
[Música]
es decir que si quieren exportar la ropa
que fabrican no les queda otro remedio
que hacerlo a través del puerto de
yibutí y ya sé lo que os estáis
preguntando ahora de verdad estamos ante
un nuevo singapur o hay gato encerrado
deberíamos imitar a bruce dickinson y
ponernos a invertir en este país hoy
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia estar en el sitio indicado
después de todo lo que os he contado
sobre yibutí muchos estaréis pensando
que como es posible que no hayamos oído
hablar antes de este país verdad la
respuesta es que la historia y la
política chubutense no es muy distinta
que la de sus vecinos
en el año 1977 tras un referéndum
pacífico y mutis se convirtió en el
último país en independizarse de sus
colonos franceses y como ocurrió en
otros casos parecidos yibutí se
convirtió en una dictadura de partido
único hasta los
cuenta el señor assange google y don y
los miembros de su tribu controlaron los
designios del país las torturas a los
miembros de la oposición se convirtieron
en una práctica habitual mientras el
partido del gobierno se hacía rico con
los beneficios del puerto
pero aquellos años llevó ti era un
ejemplo del libro de lo que los expertos
llaman un gatekeeper state perdonado por
la palabra está en inglés pero es que es
un término tan específico que no tiene
traducción en español veréis en estos
países tan pobres toda la economía se
centra en un único recurso en el caso de
guinea ecuatorial por ejemplo ese
recurso es el petróleo en el caso de
yibutí es el puerto y como estos
dictadores no tienen dinero como para
pagar a un ejército que controle todo el
país tienen que concentrar todo su
aparato represor en lo que les importa
eso explica que el puerto de yibutí
estuviera perfectamente controlado pero
que el resto del país fuera un auténtico
caos con asesinatos en las calles
violaciones y toda clase de barbaridades
como os podéis imaginar esta no es la
situación idónea para crear empresas ni
atraer la inversión extranjera
y para colmo en los años 90 estalló una
guerra civil entre el gobierno y las
tribus y partidos de la oposición y aquí
es donde llega la primera diferencia
entre yibutí y otros países de la zona
el modo en el que se resolvió el
conflicto
básicamente tras varios años de lucha y
miles de bajas en ambos lados
el señor activaron se acercó al
principal partido enemigo el movimiento
por la regeneración democrática y el
progreso y les dijo mira chicos aquí hay
dinero para todos así que por qué no nos
repartimos el poder y dejamos de
pelearnos y así es como yibutí tuvo su
primer gobierno de concentración un
gobierno que engloba a prácticamente
todos los partidos políticos por
supuesto siguen existiendo partidos en
la oposición pero a duras penas pueden
hacer campaña y siempre que hay
elecciones presidenciales intentan
boicotear las
significa que el señor assange goulet y
don y más tarde su sobrino omar que le
gana las elecciones con resultados
cercanos al cien por cien del voto os
podéis imaginar lo limpias que son esas
elecciones
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque esto es
solo el principio pese a resolver sus
luchas internas en el año 2001 y bud y
seguía siendo un país corrupto y sobre
todo con una posición muy débil
pensadlo bien hablamos de un sitio muy
pequeño con menos de un millón de
habitantes que está en el medio de una
de las regiones más violentas del
planeta a su lado tienen a somalia que
en la práctica es una anarquía donde
distintas tribus se matan entre sí al
otro lado tienen a eritrea que está
considerada como la dictadura más
salvaje del planeta y en el sur tienen a
etiopía es la mayor potencia en la
región y que en cualquier momento podría
querer invadir yibutí para tener salida
al mar vamos que no estaban ni de lejos
en una situación tranquila
y entonces cuando todo parecía estar en
su contra la historia decidió beneficiar
a los clientes
hoy en ese lugar a comer water ghost en
air comet dels ports en de repente eeuu
con george bush de presidente declara la
guerra al terrorismo y esto implica
mandar tropas a las zonas donde hay
células de al qaeda lo cual incluye el
cuerno de áfrica y que mejor lugar para
construir una base militar que yibutí la
localización es perfecta y a pesar de
que su gobierno es corrupto y viola los
derechos humanos constantemente al menos
es estable y no tiene vínculos con los
terroristas recordáis que os decía que
el mar rojo es peligrosísimo para los
barcos mercantes pues desde la base de
camp lemonier los estadounidenses pueden
perseguir a los piratas somalíes
[Música]
y no solo los estadounidenses en sólo 10
años la lista de países que han
desplegado fuerzas en yibutí es
interminable podemos encontrar tropas
francesas italianas y españolas para que
os hagáis una idea la única base militar
que tiene japón en territorio extranjero
está en este país y por supuesto con
tanta potencia internacional poniendo
sus bases militares china no se iba a
perder esta fiesta
china abre su primera base extranjera en
yibutí como os podéis imaginar en un
país tan pobre y tan pequeño tener
tantísimas bases militares supone un
auténtico espaldarazo para su economía
todos esos soldados necesitan comer en
algún sitio hacer la compra y salir a
divertirse eso significa más trabajos y
muchísimo más dinero para el país entero
pero por encima de todo elimina el mayor
problema que tenía yibutí para poder
atraer la inversión con tantísimas bases
militares en el país nadie en su sano
juicio se atrevería a invadirlo
[Música]
ahora mismo hay pocos lugares más
seguros en áfrica que yibutí si a eso le
sumamos su situación perfecta en las
rutas comerciales internacionales es
fácil entender por qué este país ha
estado creciendo a un ritmo del 5 por
ciento desde el momento en el que el
ejército estadounidense puso los pies en
el lugar sin embargo y como decimos
siempre no todo es tan bonito pese a
todo ese crecimiento yibutí continúa con
un paro de más del 50% si si habéis oído
bien 50%
y a día de hoy el puerto de yibutí las
bases militares son la única fuente de
riqueza del país en otras palabras que
esas aerolíneas que ayudó a crear
nuestro amigo bruce dickinson se limitan
a transportar a militares y cooperantes
que tienen que viajar a lugares como
somalia o etiopía pero esperad un
momento porque las cosas pueden cambiar
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
un hombre con una visión que dabas con
este nombre irías más a la ual diréis es
el nuevo presidente de yibutí pues no
para nada yibutí continúa con el mismo
presidente que tenía hace 20 años
este es el ministro de finanzas pero en
este caso el ministro de finanzas es
incluso más conocido que es su
presidente
[Música]
necesitábamos un plan a largo plazo
entendemos que lo más probable es que no
consigamos alcanzar nuestros objetivos
durante esta administración pero visión
2035 marca los objetivos para el
presidente y su gobierno si lleváis
suscritos a visual política desde hace
algún tiempo esto de visión 2035 os
sonará de algo recordáis este vídeo en
el que os hablaba del desarrollo de
ruanda pues si estoy aquí es un calco en
muchísimos aspectos el gobierno de
yibutí quiere que sus puertos tengan la
mejor tecnología y que sean comparables
a los de singapur o dubai y para eso
necesitan dinero
[Aplausos]
pero no sólo eso igual es consciente de
que para que una economía funcione es
fundamental diversificar si solo
dependemos de un único sector económico
o de una única empresa una pequeña
crisis puede hundir al país entero sin
embargo para eso para diversificar el
país necesitará otra vez dinero y sobre
todo un entorno que permita la creación
de negocios la corrupción y la falta de
estado de derecho no se lleva muy bien
con la inversión extranjera y en eso
yibutí se lleva la medalla de oro
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea pese a que
el puerto sea el gigante económico de
todo el país apenas hay información
contable disponible
eso significa que muchos oficiales del
gobierno de yibutí se están llevando
dinero a manos llenas sin que nadie
pueda ni siquiera enterarse
por si esto fuera poco parte de su
legislación está basada en la sharía y
nadie puede protestar por todo esto
porque yibutí está entre los 10 países
con menos libertad de expresión de todo
el planeta sin ir más lejos en 2016 el
gobierno encarceló a tres periodistas de
la bbc que iban a cubrir los fraudes
electorales como os podéis imaginar todo
esto lastra bastante las posibilidades
de este país y lo que es peor es
prácticamente imposible cambiar el
sistema la clase dirigente ya gana
suficiente dinero con el puerto y los
alquileres que cobran a los ejércitos
extranjeros por tener sus bases
militares
y precisamente por esto mismo tienen
suficiente seguridad como para no tener
miedo a ningún levantamiento popular en
otras palabras que si el señor bones a
dawa le ministro de finanzas de yibutí
quería cambiar el sistema político y
como dice su propio documento vice en
2035 mejorar la gobernanza del país lo
tenía bastante crudo verdad pues mis
queridos amigos de visual política a
veces los milagros ocurren
[Música]
y wood y empieza a construir una enorme
zona de libre comercio respaldada por
china dicho de otra forma si no puedes
cambiar todo el sistema político de tu
país limitarte a cambiar únicamente un
trocito del mismo en esta zona económica
especial cualquiera podrá comprar
terrenos y construir sin necesidad de
esperar meses y meses para conseguir un
permiso del gobierno y por supuesto esto
elimina las tentaciones para exigir
sobornos por otra parte todas las
regulaciones van a seguir la ley china
es algo así como una pequeña shenzhen en
mitad del país
según el acuerdo esta zona manejará
7.000 millones de dólares en comercio
dentro de dos años
yibutí eliminará los controles aduaneros
con china y establecerá un centro de
tránsito con un sistema de cambio de
divisas simplificados
y qué cabe esperar a partir de ahora
pues bien la idea de las zonas
económicas especiales no es nada nuevo y
ha demostrado que funciona es de hecho
el mismo sistema que permitió que dubai
sea la metrópoli que es hoy en día la
idea es que cuando tienes una zona
económica especial tanto los ciudadanos
como las élites políticas tienen un
escaparate de lo que ocurre cuando se
tienen leyes transparentes y ventajas
para las empresas
si este experimento funcionará las
élites políticas del país estará mucho
más dispuestas a hacer cambios reales en
el resto de yibutí en resumen que
tenemos un país africano cuya seguridad
está prácticamente garantizada por los
ejércitos de todo el mundo y que está
empezando a hacer reformas serias un
país que tiene la ubicación y el tamaño
perfecto para convertirse en el centro
financiero y logístico de uno de los
puntos más transitados en el comercio
internacional
parece que el señor bruce dickinson ha
encontrado un nuevo paraíso virgen para
la inversión
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque esto no
significa que yibutí vaya a convertirse
en ningún oasis de la libertad y los
derechos humanos a fin de cuentas ni
china ni dubai lo son ahora bien puede
que esto sea el comienzo del fin de la
pobreza en esta zona
así que la pregunta es creéis que se
cumplirán las predicciones es ahora un
buen momento para invertir en yibutí o
tal vez se quedará todo en buenas
palabras
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y si queréis conocer por que
dubai es tan rico hacer clic en este
enlace os doy una pista no tiene nada
que ver con el petróleo mientras tanto
no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribiros a
visual polític para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like
compartirlo con vuestros amigos y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]